before you can use the power of the
cloud to serve your content
you have to get your data into it in
this episode of cloud storage bytes we
talk all about the ways you can upload
data
so buckle up because we're heading to
the cloud
[Music]
when it comes to writing data into cloud
storage you have a few different options
first is the easiest option using the
cloud console
this provides you with an in-browser
experience where you can easily click to
create buckets and folders
and then choose or drag and drop the
files from your local machine to upload
second is the command line tool while
the cloud console is fine for easy
uploads and simplistic serving
situations
for production environments you often
need an automated command line solution
for this we provide the gsutil tool
gsutil is a python application that lets
you access cloud storage from the
command line
it provides you with the ability to do
all sorts of things like creating
buckets
moving objects or even editing metadata
to use it simply run the gsutil program
with a variety of command line options
for example this command uploads a
directory of files from your local
machine to your cloud storage bucket
using parallel
upload and this command lists out
specific objects that have a version
specific
url using a wild card you can see the
other cool stuff this tool can do in the
documentation linked below
up next is our client libraries at some
point you might need to interface with
cloud storage directly from your code
rather than going out to a command line
option you can include
the client libraries into your code and
call a simple api to get data into a
bucket or folder
and regardless of your language we've
got you covered
and finally if none of that suits your
fancy there's always the good old json
and xml apis
which can let you kick off an http post
request to upload data directly to a
bucket or folder
it's a bit more complicated but it's
there if you need it
now for you folks with lots of data it's
worth noting that it might not be
feasible to upload all of that data
directly from your on-prem systems to
google cloud
for that you can use the cloud storage
transfer appliance
we ship you a fancy device to your
location you can connect it and transfer
at a super
high speed and then send it back to us
plus you get this cool looking box on
your desk for a while
and don't worry if your data is on
another cloud we've got
easy to use guides to help you get up
and running with supporting a
multi-cloud environment
getting data over to google cloud
storage
and of course now that the data is in
cloud storage you've got to figure out
the best ways to serve it to your users
worldwide
but that's for another episode subscribe
give us a like
and let us know what features of cloud
storage you'd like to learn more about
thanks for joining us for this quick
bite of cloud storage
[Music]
you